President Trump tweeted a thank you to  Omarosa Manigault Newman this afternoon  attaching a video from the GOP of the  former White House aides past praise of  the president this is Omarosa released  another secret audio recording that she  says proves the president wanted to  silence her after firing her from the  White House the recording played on  MSNBC features Trump's daughter-in-law  Lara Trump offering  Omarosa a job earning $15,000 a month  the job would not require her to report  to any particular office or have a  specific set of duties other than to  speak positively on Trump's behalf as  part of his reelection campaign our  Trump responded to the tapes release  writing that it was a fraud but that the  family was concerned for Omarosa end  quote still wanted her on our team  because we cared so much about her  personally adding I am absolutely  shocked and saddened by her betrayal and  violation on a deeply personal level